des collines et des vignes à la saison
des vendanges
ce pourrait être l'alsace une visite qui
se prépare entre français ce pourrait
être la route des vins près de
strasbourg
on y va
mais le sol est un peu trop rouge et
l'herbe un peu trop sèche
le riesling est à 15000 kilomètres c'est
la route des vins sud africaine que
jeanne geneviève et yann découvre
aujourd'hui mathieu leur guide qui vit
en afrique du sud ne le relâche pas la
grappe
donc là on est sur un cépage rouge donc
à raisin rouge mais bien sûr le jus à
l'intérieur c'est un jus blanc à la
feuille je dirais ça c'est un cabernet
sauvignon
on peut l'écouter et goûter les raisins
dans le raisin de table
il ya énormément de chair mais pas
beaucoup de jus dans le raisin de cuve
ya beaucoup de jus et pas beaucoup de
chefs
et dans les visites guidées de mathieu
il y à autant de cercles de jus c'est
l'heure de déguster du raisin fermenté
dans les chais pour ce périple chic
organisé sur mesure les touristes payent
450 euros par personne pour deux jours y
compris un guide très exalté j'ai à
peine ouvert j'ai à peine levé à leur
robinet que déjà tous les arômes ont
explosé magnifique magnifique ce qui a
aussi explosé
c'est le tourisme sur la route des vins
sud africaine près de 500 mille
étrangers la parcourent chaque année
cinq fois plus qu'il ya dix ans veut pas
on recrache ça c'est pas encore tout à
fait du vin et si la question c'est lui
vincent auriol de moi ça serait du vin
celle de bois avec une bonne bière et
quand même des visites bon enfant un
brin techniques auxquelles les ouvriers
ne participe pas les touristes n'auront
pas l'occasion de les interroger
pourtant depuis novembre dernier ce sont
eux qui créent l'événement dans la
région dix neuf ans après la fin de
l'apartheid alors que les domaines
viticoles reste dirigée par les blancs
ils manifestent pour être mieux payés
mieux logés et sortir de la misère
certains sont morts dans ces combats
quels sont exactement leurs conditions
de travail
les vacanciers ont ils vont de leurs
revendications sur cette terre paisible
où résonnent rarement la colère c'est
aujourd'hui que l'histoire s'écrit
pour ce qu'il arpente la route des vins
commence souvent dans un hall d'aéroport
au cap
un matin de mars 20 vacanciers en voyage
organisé viennent d'atterrir en
provenance de france parmi eux martin
amoureuse déclaré des grands crus et de
son mari qui l'accompagnent avec son
frère et sa belle soeur chantal une
horticultrice à la retraite
tous ont un guide je m'appelle jean
camus on va se tenir compagnie
[Musique]
avant de sillonner les vignobles ils
font étape dans un quartier coloré du
cap où vivaient autrefois les esclaves
asiatiques
cette action puis ils déjeunent sur les
anciens docks première occasion pour
martine de confronter son palais au vin
du pays
[Musique]
ou pas moi j'adore le var
j'adore le cas mais j'ai décidé que je
boirai pas d'adhérer au déjeuner et que
le goût très les vins soir
on a une très courte je pense que
dans le carré d'or pourtant cinq minutes
plus tard
j'ai beaucoup de mal à résister quand
même je goûte le rose et le vert dès
pari inverse bien remplie et bien frais
l'avant-goût est prometteur chantal sa
belle-soeur attend beaucoup de la
dégustation programmée le lendemain mais
tout de même des vignes en terre sud
africaine
n'est ce pas aussi bizarre qu'un orange
et irlandais comment sont-elles arrivées
ici c'est dans la ville de franz ou que
cette cocasserie s'explique en afrikaner
la langue des colons européens
cela signifie le coin des français
car ce sont les huguenots s'est exilé
protestants qui ont importé le vin dans
la région
au xviie siècle affronte choc les
références à la mère patrie sont
visibles partout jusque dans le musée où
les panneaux sont écrits dans la langue
de molière
à la surprise de martine faut par
exemple france choquent terres
francophones
c'est ce que nous allons tirer au clair
chez un descendant de huguenots
enfin nous allons surtout goûter chez
lui l'un des meilleurs vins
sud-africains une sorte de cousin du
champagne
nous sommes avec les trois trentenaires
français et leur guide mathieu ils
poursuivent leur visite sur mesure de la
route des vins bonjour johan d'emblée
les choses sont claires
johan padan qui les accueillent ne parle
pas un mot de français
je sais juste dire d'accord
il y a trois cent cinquante ans son
aïeul a fait le voyage de france avec
des plants de vigne aujourd'hui johan
est l'un des viticulteurs les plus
célèbres d'afrique du sud
sa famille n'a cessé d'afficher la
fierté de ses racines
voilà mon père que l'on peut voir sur ce
tableau il est allé en france à la fin
des années 60 en champagne et là il a vu
comment il faisait le vin et la méthode
champenoise
vous n'êtes pas autorisés à utiliser
l'appellation champagne non ses protégés
en france c'est une appellation
contrôlée comme le chablis le champagne
sud africain donc été baptisé cap
classique et il a au moins un admirateur
français johan n'exporte aujourd'hui en
chine et aux états unis mais pas encore
en france où la concurrence serait
peut-être un peu rude
allez on déguste
tel qu'on le connaît c'est quand même
différent mais c'est peut-être un peu
plus oui facile à boire accessible et
j'aime bien aussi mais je trouve que
c'est pas sait pas ce qui peut l'être
c'est exactement comme une remorque
suivi toutes les explications qu'on a
donné c'est parce qu'on veut faire
passer le message pas ça
[Musique]
cette bouteille est vendu 22 euros mais
johan malades propose aussi des vins bon
marché jusqu'à 3 euros la bouteille
et si le prix peut descendre aussi bas
c'est en partie parce qu'en afrique du
sud
la main d'oeuvre ne coûte pas cher
[Musique]
le lendemain les trentenaires ont
justement inscrire les vendanges à leurs
programmes personnalisés
nous retrouvons geneviève janis ian au
petit déjeuner dans un hôtel de charme
en tout cas on n'a pas eu de mal de tête
s'inviter dans les vignobles au moment
de la récolte est un privilège rarement
programmé par les voyages organisés
mathieu le guide des trentenaires
connaît bien le contremaître de ce
domaine celui om va il y à 7 ans il
travaillait ici à plein temps en tant
que consultant technique
premier constat les vendanges se font
entièrement à la main la vignoble
sud-africain accueille encore que peu de
machines à la différence de la france où
elles sont employés dans plus de la
moitié des domaines deuxième constat les
ouvriers sont tous noirs comme il ne
parle pas bien anglais
janet geneviève posent peu de questions
tout juste quelques échanges timide
comme sur les crèmes de couleur jaune
dont ces femmes 112 le visage c'est pour
vous protéger du soleil
combien gagne ses ouvriers nous
interrogeons le contremaître du domaine
qui produit un vin équitable gagnent
bien leur vie pour la plupart la vie tu
gagnes combien toit pour l'afrique du
sud c'est une belle somme d'argent
elle a reçu 100 euros pour trois jours
de travail mais d'autres travailleuses
semble moins satisfaites de leur sort
est ce que le salaire est bon non il
n'est pas bon mais laissez moi j'ai peur
pourquoi je ne veux pas perdre mon
travail je ne veux pas en parler
combien gagne hôtel devant son chef elle
ne nous répondra pas sans doute bien
moins que 30 euros par jour
nous allons voir que c'est le cas de
l'immense majorité des travailleurs
viticole sud africain
[Musique]
en route pour la dégustation chantal
ajustements engagé avec le guide une
conversation sur ce thème horticultrice
à la retraite elle est très sensible aux
questions de rémunération des
travailleurs agricoles
depuis le mois de février on arrêtait le
salaire journalier en afrique du sud
pour les oubliés viticole à 150
grosso modo un 10 0 10 euro par jour
10 euros par jour beaucoup
c'est un salaire minimum de 10 euros par
jour trois fois moins que la somme
évoquée par le contremaître la
dégustation se déroule dans une salle au
style rustique
ils vont goûter à pas moins de six vins
différents
mais pour l'horticultrice qui garde en
mémoire sa conversation avec le guide
l'égorger sont amers
[Musique]
de chaque famille
une heure
puis disons
et ce salaire très modiques a pourtant
été arraché de haute lutte
c'était en janvier dernier à deux pas
des domaines visités par les touristes
cent mille ouvriers agricoles se
révoltaient sur le mode du toy toy ces
manifestations dans ces symboles de la
lutte contre l'apartheid
[Musique]
un mouvement durement réprimées par la
police
bilan des luttes trois morts et des
centaines de blessés
au final les ouvriers qui gagnait alors
5 euros par jour ont obtenu du
gouvernement le doublement de leurs
salaires mais les nouvelles lois sont
elles appliquées cette fois c'est sans
les vacanciers que nous empruntons la
route des vins nous arrivons près des
domaines les plus prestigieux au loin
des travailleurs en pleines vendanges
nous allons à leur rencontre sans en
informer le vigneron
dans ces conditions la parole est
forcément plus libre on travaille
ensemble aujourd'hui alors non je
travaille tout seul il est 10 heures du
matin et cela fait déjà quatre heures
que sarah travail elle vendanges ce
qu'on appelle des vignes debuisson
le raisin pouce au ras du sol pour le
récolter les travailleurs doivent se
pencher davantage et souffrent souvent
de douleurs aux reins
spy c'est très difficile c'est vraiment
dur ce travail le soleil me brûle et
quand il ya peu de raisons comme
maintenant qu'il est petit c'est dur de
remplir les cages au sahara été recrutés
spécialement pour les vendanges
mais willy lui travaille sur la ferme
depuis plus de dix ans
à 61 ans avec sa silhouette cassé il se
dit très fatigué ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai mal partout
j'ai des crampes surtout dans les jambes
et quand je rentre chez moi la première
chose que je fais c'est de mettre les
pieds en l'air comme le médecin me l'a
conseillé
j'ai des crampes aussi dans les mains et
je n'arrive presque plus à couper je ne
devrais plus travailler dans les vignes
parce que je ne peux plus porter de
choses lourdes sur mes épaules
vous me baisser comme ça
c'est ce que le médecin m'a dit et c'est
ce qu'il a expliqué à mon patron
mais ce que le patron a bien compris
c'est surtout que willy était moins
productifs du coup il a changé son
statut il le paye non plus à la journée
mais à la grappe de raisin forcément
willy gagnent moins d'argent
une entorse au droit du travail et nous
allons voir que ce n'est pas la seule
simon le frère de willy habite dans le
domaine viticole comme une trentaine
d'ouvriers permanent ils sont six à
partager cette maison le fermier est
tenu par la loi sud-africaine de loger
décemment ses ouvriers et de leur
procurer notamment l'électricité
voilà c'est chez moi
il vit avec sa femme dans une pièce de 5
mètres carrés depuis plus de 16 ans sema
show
les robinet d'eau chaude et d'eau froide
sont dehors sur le palier un mannequin
et pour l'électricité
comme vous pouvez voir les machines ne
fonctionnent pas comme un héros qui dit
regardez par exemple
ces deux prises là elle ne marche pas
tout est cassé sa voisine elena
partagent le même quotidien et la même
rancoeur on se lave on mange on dort on
fait tout dans un seul endroit
j'ai même dû mettre des rideaux pour
créer plusieurs pièces en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que je permis à
diviser une maison normale en quatre et
nous a mis dedans
nous sommes des adultes on ne peut pas
vivre comme ça malgré les demandes
répétées des ouvriers le fermier nos
rénove pas leur logement même les
toilettes sont à l'abandon
regardez elle ne marchait pas et vous
faites comment alors trop bas dans les
vignes
nous avons rencontré le viticulteur il
s'appelle georges sa famille exploite le
domaine depuis quatre générations
quand nous le questionnons sur les
conditions de logement de ses employés
il semble se défausser l'idée c'est que
chacun ait des toilettes chez soi on est
en train de karl et le sol on refait des
toitures il ya juste quelques maisons
qui ne sont pas aux normes
j'aimerais bien les rénover d'habitude
le gouvernement nous donne des
subventions pour le faire mais moi je
n'en ai pas
question salaire georges fait à sa façon
il ne paye pas ses ouvriers à l'heure de
travail mais à la quantité de raisins
récoltés c'est légal tant que la somme
versée à la fin de la journée n'est pas
inférieur au salaire minimum nous
retrouvons sahara c'est quoi ça pour
chaque jour on te donne un jeton ça vaut
3 centimes le décompte de ses jetons
permettra à sarah detres payer plus tard
voilà les neuf d'hier tu ne me les a pas
donné non maria simpson n'en sera sans
solde aujourd'hui sarah travailler 10
heures mais elle ne recevra que 2 euros
cinq fois moins que le salaire minimum
légal les travailleurs se serait-il
soulevait pour rien
le fermier est parfaitement conscient de
ne pas appliquer la loi la loi dit
qu'ils doivent toucher au moins 10 euros
par jour
mais s'il ne ramasse pas beaucoup de
grave c'est à moi de m'adapter
si un travailleur ne ramasse que deux
grappes de raisin je ne peux pas le
payer cette somme un bon ramasseurs doit
couper une tonne par jour ça fait 45
cageots s'il est à l'heure pour le
travail à 6 heures tous les matins c'est
possible mais hier par exemple j'en
voyais certains lézarder à l'ombre se
balader je dois leur mettre la pression
pour travailler
si l'industrie vinicole est aujourd'hui
si prospère en afrique du sud
générant 2 milliards et demi d'euros et
faisant du pays le septième producteur
de vin au monde
c'est en grande partie grâce à ses
travailleurs comment sarah vittel avec
ce bas salaires où habite elle tous les
soirs elle prend place dans ce camion où
les ouvriers plaisante sur leurs
conditions de travail
notre ferme je l'appelle cac fountain la
fontaine de la merde parce que ce qui se
passe là bas ça sent pas bon
après une demi-heure de trajet ils sont
déposés au bord de l'autoroute et sarah
doit marcher une autre demi heure
quand je rentre chez moi je n'arrive
plus à marcher tellement j'ai mal aux
pieds
elle vit dans ce bidonville un township
à l'arrière d'une cour sa cabane est
pour le moins vétustes
non non la porte est coincé vous ne
pouvez pas andré
à la mort de son mari travailleurs
viticole elle a été expulsée de sa
maison par le fermier elle y habitait
depuis dix ans aujourd'hui elle enchaîne
les petits boulots
les vendanges reste sa principale source
de revenus
en fait mon rêve serait d'être employée
de maison ou femme de ménage
pourquoi la ferme c'est trop dur
employée de maison ça paye bien si les
touristes ont rarement accès à la
réalité des travailleurs
est ce aussi le cas des importateurs
étrangers et autres connaisseurs du vin
sud-africain que saft il et quel est
leur opinion
le cap dans un palace
autour de cette table des sommeliers des
restaurateurs et des journalistes
enchaîne les dégustations à l aveugle
ces noms connus dans le milieu sont tous
français
chaque année il récompense le meilleur
vin du paint 4,80 portable voulez goûter
tous vous en discutez vous gardez vous
gardez pas ce que vous gardez pas vous
le mettez par terre je le gêne
ramènerait est-ce que vous gardez je
mettrai sur la table ici claude gilois
est un expert en vins sud africains
il travaille pour des importateurs cela
fait plus de dix ans qu'il court les
domaines une folle du vin il a souvent
entendu parler de tensions mais
l'anecdote qu'il veut nous raconter met
en pause les ouvriers et non les
propriétaires qu'il connaît bien il y
avait eu deux morts sur le domaine il
leur avait construit des pme des
baraquements mais médée des choses très
bien en plus de ça pour qu'ils puissent
vivre sur le domaine et travailler le
problème c'est que des fois le soir et
boivent un peu trop et puis et puis ils
s'entretuent
et donc il a eu deux morts ça ça ça leur
pose énormément de problèmes parce que
la promise qui arrive et c'est sais pas
c'est pas très bon pour la réputation du
domaine mais mais ne pouvait rien faire
donc
ça peut être problématique effectivement
d'avoir une communauté une petite
commune des noirs sur un domaine qui vit
ensemble aussi et surtout parce que
c'est des domaines riz du col ils ont
facilement c'est l'alcool et le nsa pas
pour ce sommelier
le problème c'est que les exploitants
agricoles n'ont pas encore tout à fait
changer d'époque et pour les blancs ont
laissé au jour d'hui à quelques quelques
vignerons qui sont entre guillemets
obligé de tendre la main mais c'est un
des grands problèmes
en clair dans le secteur du vin le
coutumier des changements brusques les
blancs continue de commander et les
noirs de vendanger
mais ceci n'est plus vrai partout comme
dans le domaine de tandis que dirige
vers donne ce businessman hyperactif de
44 ans cultive une relation de proximité
avec ses 120 employés
salut au travail et bien vous êtes
occupés vous faites quoi en ce moment on
repaye le vignoble en 1995 un an après
la chute de l'apartheid
un vigneron blanc propose à berne de
s'associer le jeune homme sort d'une
école de commerce il accepte 18 ans plus
tard il réalise un chiffre d'affaires de
600 mille euro et exportent la
quasi-totalité de sa production
après vingt ans de démocratie
seuls 3% de l'industrie sont dans les
mains de la communauté noire
je pense que ce n'est pas durable on
doit arranger ça on ne dit pas qu'il
faut que ce soit 50 50 mais pas 3%
donc il y a toujours un long chemin à
parcourir
charles et tous ceux qui sont dans notre
dynamique
on aimerait voir arriver ce jour où nous
serons juste que tout sud africain des
militants noirs mais des sud africains
qui sont dans le business du vin et tout
le monde sera content ces cantons
anniversaire tu préfères des cookies ou
des chocolats
ok jetons rapporterait d'allemagne sa
réussite commerciale vers ne la partage
avec ses employés qui sont aussi ses
actionnaires chacun touche une part des
bénéfices
nous avons deux possibilités augmenter
fortement les salaires et faire des
petits profits ou alors versé des petits
salaires et faire des gros profits
moi je pense que le mieux c'est
d'augmenter sensiblement les salaires et
avoir une meilleure vie life
au total les employés de verneuil gagne
17 euros par jour primes incluses soit
deux fois plus que le salaire minium
ils sont logés
dans les campagnes sud africaine
l'histoire est en marche
une marche très lente depuis les
manifestations
joshua syndicaliste agricole recrute de
nouveaux membres
jusqu'à présent en afrique du sud seuls
3 % des ouvriers viticoles appartenait à
une organisation
le taux le plus bas parmi tous les
métiers du pays bonjour vous avez fini
de travailler vous pouvez m'expliquer la
route pour venir s'il vous plaît
aujourd'hui je choix va rencontrer 25
travailleurs et ils ont peur de le
recevoir
encore aujourd'hui c'est très difficile
les fermiers font tout pour dissuader
leurs ouvriers de se syndiquer et pour
nous empêcher de venir
ils mettent des barrages on doit
demander la permission de rencontrer les
travailleurs
ce n'est pas comme dans les autres
compagnies nous partons pour une ferme
isolée loin des circuits touristiques à
l'eau je suis prêt des abricotiers vous
êtes ignore pourquoi ce bourg
joshua suit les explications de son
contact pour éviter d'être vu par le
fermier
la réunion à laquelle nous allons
assister est secrète à la demande de cet
homme envers le leader des ouvriers sur
le domaine nous troquons notre caméra
pour une caméra cachée les travailleurs
hésitent encore à se syndiquer et il
craint que notre tournage ne les
perturbe
ils sont 20 dans cette cabane en ce
dimanche après midi
très vite les doléances fusent faibles
revenus logement insalubre absence de
suivi médical
l'atmosphère est pesante je vais vous
dire une chose qui est fondamental tout
le monde s'engage
ou alors on laisse tomber il n'y a pas
de demi mesure parce que ce qui va se
passer à la fin du conte c'est que le
fermier va essayer de diviser ou did
il y aura le préféré non syndiqués et le
pestiféré qui aura signé et ce sera
grave pour tout le monde
une heure plus tard joshua les aura
convaincus malgré les risques encourus
tous vont s'inscrire aujourd'hui
francine hockey lna
ok prix d'une cotisation 3 euros un
tiers d'une journée de salaire
[Musique]
aucun inspecteur du travail n'est jamais
passé sur ce domaine
dans la région seuls une dizaine de
fermiers ont été verbalisés parce qu'ils
n'appliqueraient pas la loi
c'est donc en jeu choix que c'est
travailleurs place désormais tous leurs
espoirs
quelques pas au dessus de l'océan comme
une bouffée d'air sur un balcon
demain martine chantal et leurs maris
prendront l'avion pour rendre visite aux
tribus zoulou dans le sud ouest du pays
ils seront à 1600 km de la route des
vins loin de ce crépuscule magique sur
le cap régaler les papilles avec le vin
se régalent les cieux
qu'est ce que c'est
pas un seul des vacanciers n'a rapporté
en france une bouteille sud africaine
une simple affaire de goût ou
l'impression qu'il y a comme un loup
quelque part comme si ces vignobles
l'apartheid résiste encore n'était pas
tout à fait prêt à s' offrir aux regards
des visiteurs
[Musique]